ANJALI KUMAR: It's Lunch Time
at Google with Anjali Kumar.
Today our guest is Chef
Jacques Pepin.
JACQUES PEPIN: Hello.
Happy cooking.
ANJALI KUMAR: Well, thank
you so much for
coming by my office.
I know you're busy.
And I know you had your big
event this morning.
But I brought you a sandwich,
because I know
we're pressed for time.
JACQUES PEPIN: Yes, it's good.
ANJALI KUMAR: Do you
like cabbage?
JACQUES PEPIN: I like.
I love anything.
ANJALI KUMAR: Oh, great.
JACQUES PEPIN: Especially
anything free.
ANJALI KUMAR: Anything
for free.
I'm the same way.
JACQUES PEPIN: This is to imbibe
the Beaujolais that I
drank this morning.
ANJALI KUMAR: It's not
even noon, Jacques.
JACQUES PEPIN: I had a bottle
at 10 o'clock this morning
because I became a member of
the Association of the
Beaujolais Nouveau in France.
ANJALI KUMAR: So you're
drunk right now?
JACQUES PEPIN: Some type of way
of making you drink wine
early in the morning
for breakfast.
ANJALI KUMAR: Are you a little
tipsy right now, or are you--
JACQUES PEPIN: No, no.
I mean, I'll be tipsy looking
at you, but not from the
Beaujolais.
ANJALI KUMAR: I like him.
What is your favorite
thing to eat?
JACQUES PEPIN: Free food.
ANJALI KUMAR: What is your
least favorite food?
JACQUES PEPIN: Expensive food.
ANJALI KUMAR: Which of these
typical American
meals is your favorite?
Sloppy joe--
JACQUES PEPIN: I--
ANJALI KUMAR: Oh, no.
I'm going to give you a list.
JACQUES PEPIN: Oh, great.
ANJALI KUMAR: Sloppy
joes, "American"
cheese, or pizza rolls?
JACQUES PEPIN: I go
for sloppy joe.
ANJALI KUMAR: Really?
You heard it here.
JACQUES PEPIN: I like
gooey stuff.
ANJALI KUMAR: You had a
much-loved TV series with
Julia Child.
JACQUES PEPIN: Oh, yes.
Thank you.
ANJALI KUMAR: "Julia
and Jacques."
JACQUES PEPIN: Yes.
ANJALI KUMAR: And I have a
couple of behind-the-scenes
questions for you.
Who spoke better French?
JACQUES PEPIN: Who spoke
better French?
Her, of course.
No, she was-- her
French was good.
Actually, I met her
in 1960, 6-0.
And the first time I met her at
the friend of mine in New
York, she was unknown
at that point.
But the friend, Helen McCully,
the food editor for "McCall"
and "House Beautiful," and
she said, oh, yeah, that
manuscript, I received it.
You want to take a look?
So I took a look, and
[? jeez, ?] it's very good.
And she says, well, the woman
is coming from California.
She's a woman from California
coming next week.
Let's cook for her.
She's a big woman with
a terrible voice.
So [INAUDIBLE], and that's
how I met Julia.
And that first time we spoke
French, because she just came
from France.
And I hadn't been
here that long.
And my English was not as
good as her French.
ANJALI KUMAR: Can you do an
impression of her for us?
JACQUES PEPIN: (FALSETTO) Yes,
of course, I can do an
impression of--
You know who did that
was my daughter.
My daughter was born, I already
knew Julia Child.
So Claudine always made
her impression.
And she was at Boston
Universitaire, as well.
So she used to call.
And one night, I was eating
dinner with my wife.
The telephone rang.
Gloria pick it up.
She say, OK, OK, Claudine.
What do you want?
We're eating now.
And she said, oh, no, no.
I'm sorry, Julia.
I'll call him.
She thought it was Claudine
doing her impression,
[? yelling ?] at Julia.
'Cause Julia, every time she
called, she would say,
(FALSETTO) Hi, this
is Julia Child.
Like you wouldn't
know who she is.
ANJALI KUMAR: Well, you
have a new book.
JACQUES PEPIN: Good.
Yes.
ANJALI KUMAR: It's
just come out.
Can you tell us about it?
JACQUES PEPIN: This
is the technique.
And by "technique," you mean
something which has to do with
[? manutention, ?]
with repeat, with repeat.
And that way, it
doesn't change.
The way you beat an egg
white, or do an
omelette, or peel an asparagus.
You do the same thing now that
it was 50 years ago.
Although I don't cook now the
way I cooked 50 years ago, but
the technique remain.
And that's why that
book is here.
ANJALI KUMAR: What would you say
is the one technique that
everybody should know
but doesn't?
JACQUES PEPIN: Certainly
sharpening a knife.
And each time I go, they say,
oh, we had the knife sharpened
because we know you
are coming.
I take the knife and I say,
which side did you sharpen?
Sharp knife is good.
But you have a good knife,
a good bowl, a good pot.
You don't need that many.
And now you start doing soup--
think simple, good.
I mean at home, we do what my
wife called Fridge Soup.
Anything in the fridge left
over, I put it in a pot, I
make the soup.
ANJALI KUMAR: That's
a good recipe.
JACQUES PEPIN: Yes.
ANJALI KUMAR: Mine
would be largely
mustard, sriracha, vinegar.
JACQUES PEPIN: I didn't
know Google was
that good at sandwich.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
We're good at many things,
search and sandwiches.
JACQUES PEPIN: That's good.
ANJALI KUMAR: Yeah.
JACQUES PEPIN: I will remember
Google for sandwich.
ANJALI KUMAR: (LAUGHING) You've
had a couple of drinks
today, haven't you, Jacques?
Are you going to finish
that other half?